Welcome everybody to today's Zoom call. We have some questions to get to get started with. So let's jump right into the questions that people have submitted in every binder to everybody.
If you have questions that you have thought about beforehand, you want to make sure that they get answered on a Zoom call, just email them to the clinic.
Just please in the reference part of the email, put Zoom call questions because we literally get hundreds of emails a day and they could get lost real easy. So please put Zoom call questions in the email.
Okay, good question here. I noticed that the rife machine gives me various frequencies over time.
So that's right. When we write a program, there's various frequencies in that person's program.
And they can range on a dwell meeting. That's how long that frequency is running anywhere from five seconds, three seconds to three minutes, sometimes longer.
I noticed that it gives us various frequencies. That would mean that one program goes through different frequencies actually.
In my understanding breast cancer, for example, has one specific frequency and the rife would target this by using the same frequency to make the cells go into lysis.
Correct me. If I'm wrong, my question is, what is the reason for using various different frequencies?
If one cancer has one frequency that it ties with, what are the other frequencies good for? And why are we running those?
So I will correct you. You are not corrected. So cancer does not have one frequency. Breast cancer does not have one frequency that causes the cells to go into lysis.
So rife believe that if you could hit the cancer cell at its frequency, you could cause lysis. So let me back up and explain this.
There's different ways that cells die. The normal way that cells die. So your cells, both your cells in your body will die and reproduce before they die.
And they go through a process of cell that called apoptosis.
It's really more of a recycling of those cells when they die. So the parts of the cell are broken down for these blabs, that's what it's called, break down your lysis zones in the cells, break it out and basically reuse the components of the cells.
So it's like a recycling.
There's another way that cells die pathologically, but that's called lysis. So if you're exposed to arsenic because you ate a rat poise leaf and you died, it's because you had an overabundance of poison that caused cells to go into lysis and killed your healthy cells and you passed away.
So lysis is a pathological death of a cell. That's the way chemotherapy works.
Some cells can go through apoptosis with chemotherapy. Both cells go through lysis. That's one of the reasons why you end up feeling sick with chemotherapy.
It's killing healthy cells. What is that? It's causing healthy and unhealthy cells, hopefully more unhealthy cells, a cancer cells to go through lysis.
And what a cell goes through lysis it literally just breaks apart and you end up with all these what are called exendotoxins, meaning toxins from your body themselves that you're then has to be carried away by your lip system and in deposited in through your phase one phase two pathways and you're liver into your gut and you have to get rid of them.
So that's a toxic cell death that it could cause all sorts of problems. Well, I think what this person is referring to is that they've read some stuff on royal rife himself and he believed that the rife machine if you hit the cancer with just the right frequency, you could go through lysis because you can't actually demonstrate that you could cause immediate cell death of a single cell organism. There's YouTube videos out there that show hitting a paramecium right at the right.
Frequency can cause the paramecium to implode and just break apart and you'd have all these toxins if that paramecium was in your body. That's what happens to bacteria when you use the rife a sheet single cell organisms like bacteria can be broken apart and killed by hitting them at the right frequency.
But even that there's multiple frequencies that a strap bacteria would have.
Because it's functioning differently, it could have multiple frequencies.
Same thing with breast cancer. So a very specific breast cancer could there could be 200 different frequencies of that breast cancer.
So there are with breast cancer, for example, there's hundreds of different known frequencies that can effectively help breast cancer. Now personally, I don't believe the rife causes lysis at all.
I think the rife causes stimulation of that cell if you can hit it its own frequency and causes your body to stimulate an immune response to it.
When your immune cells kill a cell, it stimulates an external source of apoptosis. There's different apoptotic pathways.
So when your immune system kills a cell, it goes through apoptosis. Still not to realize this.
So no, there is not just one frequency for a specific cancer. There's multiple frequencies. So when we write a person's program, we're putting in those multiple frequencies for cancer.
We're also putting in other frequencies to help with liver function, help with kidney functions so that you can detoxify and stay as healthy as possible.
We're not just putting in. There isn't just one frequency. There's multiple frequencies. And we're not solely treating the cancer with your overnight program or treating the rest of your body to be as healthy as possible.
So when there's different times where people as I talk to them, in the case review, that they have multiple problems. So not everybody just has cancer. Maybe somebody has an issue with CDF or somebody has an issue with h pylori will put that programming in their life as well, because that's an issue that could kill a person too.
So there's different things that we put in your program so that hopefully that answers that question.
Wow, did this cut this off. So let me make this screen a little bit bigger.
So this question says, all right. So this over, I understood that cancer doesn't like oxygen. And therefore, it's a good to bring more oxygen into the bloodstream.
At the same time, many supplements are antioxidants, which sounds counterproductive to exposing the cancer to oxygen.
Okay, so there's a difference between oxidizing agents and oxygen, which is O2.
So oxygen in your bloodstream is beneficial. Your cells need oxygen in order to make energy. You need oxygen as part of the metabolic pathways cancer.
So cancer has multiple ways that is sourcing its food. So it has multiple fuel sources.
It can feed off of amino acids like glutamate and methionine and lysine. And it can feed mainly off glycolysis.
So glycolysis is the way in the mitochondria of the cell that your body, the mitochondria takes glucose and breaks it down through this process called glycolysis to produce pyruvic acid.
And then ultimately acetyl coenzyme that goes into the crem cycle, not to get too much into biology here, but the crem cycle really kicks out ATP.
So the purpose of glycolysis is to kick out ATP energy and then to finalize with two pyruvic acids that then translate to two acetyl coenzymes A that then go into the crem cycle or citric acid cycle.
And kick out a whole bunch of ATP energy. So that's how your body makes energy uses glucose to make energy. So glucose is necessary. So if you didn't have any glucose in your system, you would die.
So, but if you have too much glucose, it can affect the cell membranes and it could cause what's called diabetes, we'll get into that.
But cancer, you've heard is cancer is fed by sugar. So stay away from sugar. Yes, you should stay away from gross sugars like cookies, cakes and candies and things. But we don't want to eliminate all glucose all the time, your healthy cells need glucose to make energy and you would be very fatigued if you're at a state of hypoglycemia.
Well, through the glycolysis and through the crem cycle, especially the crem cycle, you need oxygen. So that's another co factor in the crem cycle.
So if a person isn't breathing well, it has a low blood oxygen content, then they can decrease their amount of ATP energy made and that could be not a good thing.
And a decrease amount of oxygen can leave a lot of the end point of glycolysis pyruvic acid in the system.
Pyruvic acid is really the culprit that cancer feeds on.
So cancer feeds on pyruvic acid, not so much sugar, but well, well, sugar breaks down the glucose and sugar breaks down the pyruvic acid and that's really what the thing that cancer feeds on.
So if a cancer patient is deficient in oxygen, aka, they're laid around a lot and not getting exercise, then they can be deficient in oxygen and they can have excess pyruvic acid, another word for pyruvic acid is pyruvate.
And the excess pyruvate pyruvic acid in your system, it can be a fuel source for cancer.
Well, we don't want that. So one of the ways that you can help is to decrease the amount of sweets that you're eating. That question came in is fruit, a good source of glucose. Well, fruit is a source of glucose that does break down to glucose.
But fruit has other benefits and other nutritional pieces to it. So fruit is much better source of sugar in your body that eating sugar cane sugar table sugar cookies cakes other simple carbohydrates.
So we don't want excess pyruvate in our body. So oxygen helps decrease that pyruvate.
When we're talking about oxidizing agents, that's a totally different thing. So oxidizing agents damage our cell membranes, oxidizing agents.
One class of oxidizing agents is a poison really an oxidizing agent is a poison.
And to what degree that you're exposed to that oxidizing agent is the damage that you'll have.
A person could eat could drink some water laced with benzene, which is an oxidizing agent.
And depending how much is in there, it could either kill them, or it could damage their cells, it could damage their heart, whatever wherever that oxidizing agent gets to, of course, your heart is going to be a major call for blood sugar glycolysis and your first call for nutrition.
So it could be the same that's damaged and it could kill a person or could damage their heart for life, even if they survive.
So an oxidizing agent could cause cancer. So glyphosate, herbicides, things like that are oxidizing agents and they can damage cell membranes damage by the country damage other components of the cell and can be a cause of cancer.
So again, step back, understand, chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent. Well, it's bad then. Well, it could cause cancer. Well, yes, chemotherapy can cause cancer.
The idea is we're going to give just the right amount that it's going to kill the cells that are the bad guys. So we're going to kill the cancer before we kill the patient.
That's the idea of chemotherapy. I'm not knocking chemotherapy, but that's just what it is. So, but oxidizing agents can cause cancer can cause other things. So we do want to decrease our burden of oxidizing agents when we're when we have any disease process or even before we have a disease process would even be better so that it would help us from possibly getting some disease processes.
How do you do that? You take specific antioxidants. Well, question was about fruit, fruits have antioxidants in it. So you can get a lot of this nutrition through your food.
So the idea of supplementing using a supplement like alpholopac acid, vitamin C, curcumin, different things like that. They're oxidizing agents that's one component of how those things work.
They had two other things to their immune stimulants and other things, but they have antioxidant capability. So they're anti oxidizing agents. So you take antioxidants to decrease your load of oxidizing agents that we're all exposed to.
You went and pumped gas and breathed in those gas foods. Those are oxidizing agents. You take vitamin C. You take alpholopac acid. You take an acetylcystine. You take glutathione producers and stimulants to help get rid of those things and help protect yourselves.
So don't confuse oxidant speedy oxygen to into oxidizing agents, which are poisons.
I probably gave you way too many words to answer that question. Sorry about that.
Next question. I am on the so called Kibo tablets, which I take twice a day. And I am also taking a lot of supplements.
Some antioxidants, Dr. Cutters mentioned that we will speak on this later. So here's a good time to do so.
So I would like to pick it up and would be happy to get more insights into this topic of oxidizing Kibo tablets and taking antioxidants.
So the question is, is what do I do if I'm on chemotherapy by my oncologist doesn't want me on any supplements because he doesn't want me on antioxidants while I'm doing chemotherapy.
Well, if I'm on chemotherapy infusions once every three weeks, I would agree. There's about a 48 hour window that the chemotherapy is really working. So stay away from any antioxidants during that 48 hour window.
So part of our chemotherapy protocol is during that 48 hour window after chemotherapy, don't take it at all for the pick acid and it's at a single cyst.
Or vitamin C, the made antioxidants stay away from those during that 48 hour window.
What do I do if I'm on a daily Kibo pill? Why just not take any antioxidants anymore?
Well, that's where it gets a little confusing and you kind of got to weigh this out.
Well, if I take it into oxidant, an alphalopeic acid, same time I take my Kibo pill, could it be reducing the effect of the Kibo pill? Well, it could.
So if you're going to take the oncologist standard of medicine point of view, yes, it will. So don't take it into oxidant while you're doing any Kibo, including a Kibo pill.
My approach is and then there's the far right approach of the nutritionist who says, no, it won't the antioxidants going to protect your healthy cells first.
It's not going to be protecting your cancer cells.
And there may be a lot of truth to that. My approach is more middle of the ground.
If you're taking a Kibo pill once a day, then take your antioxidants away from that. Take your other supplements away from that.
I would fall more so on that far right side that I don't think that antioxidants are really going to protect the cancer cells. They're going to be protecting your healthy cells more so, but I don't have any proof of that.
So I would say, stay, you know, take your antioxidants just away from meeting time wise of your Kibo pill next question.
I read that it is likely to experience that is likely to experience a small electrical shocks during use of the right.
I honestly haven't felt anything any electrical shocks is that the one.
So it's it's not very common that a person feels electrical shocks, whether using the right.
Usually happens in drier months, when there's a lot of static electricity in the air, when you have a lot of static electricity in your house, if you are dehydrated or the house is dehydrated.
That doesn't happen always even at that. So it's it is it can be.
It can be that's necessarily common, but that I'm calling, but it's it's not something you're looking for. So next question.
I seem to have several persistent conditions that started prior to the right for she use.
This is a person that just started with the right to start it with us.
And these are these conditions persist to today.
What is little to no appetite taste buds. That's so good. All foods have no or blame taste.
You can do this person's history a little bit, but there's some things that could cause lack of appetite.
Lack of taste and it can be anything for the slightest condition to be noticed with a virus of as of late, that you can lose your taste.
So virus infections viral infections that affect the nasal glands can cause that anything that can affect old factory.
Taste can cause that your taste buds are intervened by credit or there are 11 so anything that's affecting that can cause taste issues to typically keep a therapy does that anybody who's been on keyboard therapy has lost their taste so that we have to dig into some personal things about this person.
Tiredless low energy. Well, that's probably the most common complaint of a person with cancer. That's how I notice personally, if I if I'm noticing a lot more fatigue and my energy is just I just feel down to the dumpside know that my cancer is active.
For me, raise got it hasn't been that hasn't been since March, but but that's that's a very common issue with people with cancer and why is that because a cancer that's active is sucking up all your glucose because it's trying to feed on pyruvate for sure looking for a fuel source and then your other cells don't get that.
What does what does your other cells do with glucose? It makes energy that I explained that like the more than anybody wants to know a few minutes ago. So that's the biggest complaint that a person with cancer has is low energy.
Test and back pain difficult to rise from a prone or sitting position.
I get it. I have to dig into the specifics of what where this person's cancer is if a person has chest pain or back pain upon a rising.
You have to ask is it because I stood up and I by chest hurts so I have chest pain because I stood up.
I was eating that it has nothing to do with my spine or the physical condition of my muscles. It's because your heart had to increase its blood pressure upon a rising and it could be a heart issue.
So that's something you may want to get checked out is just where your blood pressure is at.
The pressure does have to go up 10 points just for the seated position to a stand position and that if it doesn't, it can be because it can be because of a adrenal insufficiency.
So if there's an adrenal insufficiency, a person can have dizziness to feel a little bit fate upon standing and it can tie to tiredness and low energy.
And with no cancer and some faithness upon a rising from a seated or lying down position, the first thing a person should think of is adrenal insufficiency.
And that should be addressed if you could by first go to with any adrenal insufficiency is adaptogenic herbs.
We have them on our website, on our store site, there's multiple different adaptogens. So really contact our offices if that's an issue.
But you do want to if there's chest pain upon a rising, make sure you get your heart checked out as well. So if it's just a physical because your back muscles are sore and your spine is sore, you do want to get that checked out to make sure you don't have any some osteoarthritis, which is really common in the upper back and neck area too.
Constant salt saliva tastes in by both by myself wanting to expel accumulated saliva frequently.
That's a good question. There's multiple possible answers to that one. I don't know off the top of my head what you're dealing with with that.
Let's dig into that what a little deeper. So we'll have a great question, a great answer for that I apologize.
Questions for the chat. What do you do with the cheek swabs?
I had several cheek swabs in my binder, wondered how often they should be sent in. Oh, good question. So in your binder, it does state.
If you do want a kinesiology, recheck, then that's what you use the cheek swabs for. Do a cheek swab, put it the light bag, seal it up and mail it back in.
But you do have to email this person as a distance person. You do have to email Ashley, you're the liaison or if you came to the office and be in and you tell them I'm sending a cheek swab in because I want you to check.
Maybe I want to recheck on my supplements or I'm not feeling well. I don't know what's wrong with me. I have these symptoms.
XYZ and can you please check this? That's we do kinesiology out and we'll recheck things. Some people.
That doesn't happen, but every six months, some people don't ever do that. Some people do it every month. Everybody's different. It's totally your choice.
I have a tumor that is right next to the brainstem. We radiated the tumor with less radiation by the brainstem. Now eight months later, we are noticing there. There is either injury or the tumor is waking up.
They want me to take a steroid for swelling. I had that before and got blood clots. So is there something else I could take in place of a steroid.
Yes, there is. There's nothing that will decrease inflammation faster than taking a steroid. I'll tell you that.
The problem with taking a steroid is long-term steroid use can decrease weight. Let's not count. So it can suppress the immune system.
Oh, well, I don't have a suppressed immune system with cancer. So with my brain cancer patients, I think that it's far better to be on a low-no steroid like two milligrams twice a day.
That it is to have inflammation of the brain and not being able to get nutrition or healing there because of the inflammation of the brain.
So you have to weigh that out. But in this case, hey, I'm not having horrible symptoms yet. They want me to go on the steroid. Could I do something else? Yes.
So the anti-inflammatory nutritional things, the different herbs, you'd think of number one, curcumin or tumeric.
So tumeric slash curcumin is top anti-inflammatory for anywhere in your body and definitely the brain. So I would think that there's white willow bark.
There's Boswellia. There's Stiggy dental. There's multiple other herbs too. We have a product that's called clear inflame. That's a capsule. That is a great anti-inflammatory that you can take.
It's it's our private label of designs for health and flabatone. So you might get it under that label and you could take that.
We also have a product called BAM that we make ourselves and it stands for braid anti-inflammatory mix because I actually invented it for brain inflammation, but it's kind of a misnomer. I should just change it to body and anti-inflammatory mix because it's still BAM.
Because it's not going to be specific to the brain, it's going to be for the whole body. That's a powder. But I did it in a powder because people wanted to put it in their smoothies.
The issue with like the inflame tone, the clear inflame is you have to take a lot of those capsules and you have to take a lot of these anti-inflammatory.
So if you want to really decrease inflammation in the brain, for instance, you really want to get up to about five grams of curcumin, five grams, like capsules are only 500 milligrams.
Well, you're taking 10 of those a day. Another really good product for inflammation that we started using just a couple of years ago is a product that is patented.
It's getting the anti-inflammatory enzyme from beats. So you don't get any sugar from the beats, but it's just the enzyme from the beats.
It's a product called Limitless. Limitless. L-I-M-I-T-L-E-S-S. For just general inflammation taking a couple of those a day for inflammation that we're talking here about inflammation of the brain, maybe five or six a day.
The problem is not a real cheap product, but it does really work well. But I would still do curcumin. I would try to get up to about equivalent to about five grams a day on that.
I would still look at the clear inflame or the brain anti-inflammatory mix. If you're making smoothies because the brain anti-inflammatory mix doesn't taste that good.
But if you throw it into a berry smoothie or a protein shake or something like that, you really don't taste it that much.
And you can take a whole table spoon. And we just sell that just at cost. It's a powder.
It's that flavored or anything. It's all organic. It's a great anti-inflammatory mix, but you really have to be doing a smoothie otherwise it's really hard.
Question can limitless be used for any kind of inflammation? Yes. Yeah. It's not anything for any type of inflammation. None of these products that we just talked about are for any specific type of inflammation.
It is, it's going to affect your whole body. So anything you're going to take orally, it's going to affect your whole body. It's not going to just go to the brain or just go here or there.
Okay. Next question.
I want to get the nerve accelerator for face to detox.
The on the bottle it says, Bethel genetic nutrition. The label shows all antioxidants. What is the meaning of Bethel on the bottle?
So Bethel genetic nutrition is just the name is just that line of nutrition from professional health products.
So the nerve accelerator is a product from professional health products that they have multiple different lines that they sell under that they're that they're just brand deed the product as Bethel genetic nutrition.
What's this whole line of brand that they have a nutrition that was created around genetic testing.
So that's all that means there's no Bethel products in the product themselves itself. So, okay, how we do it if you want to ask a question that you'll need to raise your hand if you want to speak and or don't raise your hand just unmute yourself.
So you can see with our talk today that some of these questions, you know, we're really good questions to ask to a group.
Because they weren't specific about us specific thing that was going on with you.
And some of these questions were hard to answer because they're going to be there's some generality to the question and then there's some things that are going to be really specific to that person that this person said these questions and not necessarily wanting to have them on a zoom call.
So that's okay.
If we have a question that's that's very specific to what's going on with you that it's probably best to chat with your liaison either internationally or set up a time that we can talk so we can get to the bottom of what's going on with you.
But there's some generality that we can learn from all these so I think they're I just thought it was good to still put it on here next question do we have to be careful not to have the wires of the bulb cross.
The wires of the bulb cross what using the put back.
I'm not so I don't I think it partly has to do with your electricity in your house how much dirty electricity you have how much surges you have in your electricity and such.
I can have an effect maybe that's a good practice to adhere to.
But I'm not I don't have the perfect answer for that I think it's different with people's electricity.
Next question people with mold or Candida can't eat mushrooms but they still use mushroom extracts.
That's a really good question I get that question often when I'm talking to people individually.
My answer is yes there's some practitioners and say no they should use muster mushroom extracts either.
I don't agree with I just don't agree with that so I but I do believe that there are people that are can be sensitive to anything so they can certainly be sensitive and react to mushroom extracts even not having mold or Candida so.
Nothing is perfect for everybody so you do have to be careful about that so you do have a history of mold or Candida.
Then just test it you know try it see if you react negatively to it or have any effect negatively then be careful about that.
What is the degalace test and are you offering it the degalace test is measuring degalace in the blood which is an enzyme and it's only done in a lab in Europe.
There is a there is a they have a sub lab in where is Oklahoma or something like that where you said the test to and then it gets sent off to Europe.
I know I think it's a good test and it's a test that is that you could kind of monitor your cancer with so I think it's a valid test and it's accurate.
I know they are having trouble offering it at estates for a while last year I think they're back up track again.
I tell people know what they want to monitor their test and that could take three four weeks to get it back probably better off doing the HCG test that you said that to the Philippines with because it's far less expensive the degalace test can be two three four hundred dollars.
One of the Philippines is what 65 dollars still takes three weeks to get it back just make sure if you're doing the one of the Philippines that you said it's regular male so this looks like a letter so that the bad guys don't think it's there's value in it and compass can't avail so don't send it any other way just but regular USPS.
What are your thoughts on EFF causing radiation.
Do you recommend any devices it's said to protect yourself.
Yeah so EFFs can be very dangerous especially for those with brain cancer with those with mold with those with lime with those with the specific gene.
That if you have defects in this one gene family you're going to be more sensitive to EFFs.
They're not good for any of us certainly five G is tonight thoughts probably just a weapon.
It is it's very dangerous so what do you do protected that's the tricky part.
If you if you're very sensitive to EFF you stop using a cell phone or you keep your cell phone in a.
Faraday cage sleeve we have those available on our store for very inexpensive there are cloth sleeve that you just put yourself on it and you can put it in the pocket and literally shuts your cell phone off the negative of using that is it literally shuts your cell phone off from any.
Receiving any messages so if you turn your cell phone off it could still receive messages and still be a source of EFFs.
But if you put it in a little Faraday sleeve you literally block everything so you you you could the cell phone itself will still run a turtle in turtle things like like an alarm so if I have a alarm set for right now if I have it in the Faraday sleeve it'll the alarm will still go off and I can hear it so I can put it out of the sleeve and turn my alarm off.
But in the sleeve I can't receive any calls I can't receive any text I can't receive any messages anything like that but if I as soon as I pull it off my sleep just like if you just turn on a phone if you turn it off it'll go dig dig dig dig dig dig you have seven messages so
But that's a good way to protect it you can put it well you're not using your phone you don't need to receive phone calls right now.
You're just kind of putting your phone to sleep by slipping it into a sleeve so back to where do you get EFFs and how do you protect it you get EFFs okay number one from cell phone towers and from your cell phone that's the biggest source of EFFs.
You get you get you can't let's you move away from all cell phone towers you're going to be exposed to it so the farther you away are for the cell phone tower the better you're off or you are number two.
By keeping your phone protected we also have key drugs that you can put on the back of your phone but they don't work nearly as good as a Faraday sleeve.
There's EFFs that come from your Wi-Fi we have Wi-Fi router bags that you put over your Wi-Fi router that block a lot of the EFFs but still allow some of the Wi-Fi to go through so they're not as strong as those sleeves it's otherwise that shut off your Wi-Fi.
Good idea is to shut off your Wi-Fi at night you know using a date have it on a little strip that you could just click the button and shut off the Wi-Fi at night you can shut it back out of the morning.
Protect your house from dirty electricity eventually early your earlier dirty electricity as surges in your electrical system where you're getting EFF exposure just from your house and your your own electrical wires that run around your house that you're exposing your stuff.
That's with the static products that we have on our website too.
I have our house connected to a whole house static box that I had an electrician wire in.
And then so those are the main things you can look on our store and search EFFs on our store and you'll see a whole bunch of different products that will help protect you and that's the whole idea it's about helping protect you nothing is going to keep you from EFFs there is EFF clothing out there.
Again, it doesn't block all EFFs better what they say but it is helpful so anything is a help so to the people that are very sensitive at EFFs that they're going all those routes as many of those as possible the better and they find that they feel a lot better.
There's actually an area in the United States in Virginia that there's no EFFs and it is an area that is blocked because it's I think it's around the Hubble telescope or something like that or some big telescope or something.
So with an eight mile radius there's there's no EFFs and people that are highly sensitive to EFFs have actually physically moved there now you can't get internet you can't get anything there nothing.
So there's no Wi-Fi no internet your cell phones don't work you have to drive out of the area to get cell phone coverage.
But it could really calm people's nervousness and that have highly sensitivity to EFFs I had a patient with brain cancer once that she they had to unplug they had to move her husband had to move their refrigerator out the garage she couldn't have any appliances going in the house where she would start to have a seizure.
And so that went on for a couple of years I think before we got the inflammation down to the point that she was able to bring your refrigerator back in the house but interesting case so any inflammation of the brain is going to cause an increase sensitivity to EFFs you see that with any microglial private cause from concussions microglial private cause from
from the two births or brain cancer and any kind will cause a sensitivity to EFFs. Any other questions by the way that question about not wanting to do radiation again on the brain stem I actually have a video on what I just mentioned because I just thought of it saying it microglial private I think it's a just search on our blog braided inflammation.
I think it'll be under that they have a video on what what microglial private is so and what to do about it so we go over all those anti inflammatory things so that will give you some more insight in that if you want to watch that video and learn more about that.
How do you feel about three five or 10 day fast water only or diluted juice 10 water to one part juice okay so also I'm going to answer the question but I will point you to our blog post about fasting mimicking dieting and intermittent fasting and
TRE which is type restricted eating so the information about fasting I know we have cancer patients that have fasted and 10 day fasted felt like it really clean up or really helped out their cancer so I'm not going to diminish the fact that that can work for people but the studies on fasting are after 24 hours fasting your IGF one levels go up.
So IGF would help is is part of the growth hormone factors so that's not good for a cancer patient so there is benefit to doing longer fasts but for cancer patient we don't recommend more than a 24 hour fast for that reason.
So we recommend if you want to fast fast you know you can fast to 24 hour fast but then break it eat and then you could you know eat for you know a day and then you can go on another fast but do it more than a 24 hour fast raises IGF one levels according to all the studies so you do increase growth factors that's good if you don't have cancer you do want to raise IGF one levels to a point
because growth hormone helps build muscle helps build tissue so it can be beneficial but not with cancer patients so we don't recommend more than a 24 hour fast and we recommend time restricted eating.
So be eating that you're only going to eat within a window of maybe five hours of the day so you're going to skip breakfast skip lunch you're going to eat at three o'clock and you'll eat till eight o'clock I'm not talking about eating the whole time but that's your window of eating and then you stop eating till the next day till three o'clock so that's time restricted eating it's also intermittent fasting in a way so just look at our blog about that that will help explain that too.
Will the hyperbaric oxygen chamber be helpful in reaching my brain tumor the answer is absolutely so hyperbaric oxygen really shines with brain issues not just brain cancer but with any brain issues so hyperbaric oxygen is a great tool for a lot of things helps with other tissues to not just brain but most the studies and hyperbaric are with brain cancer.
With Parkinson's with dementia so the negative about HBOT is that you got to do it very regularly so we are our HBOT and our office is the most under use piece of equipment that we have because most of our patients are not local and if you have breast cancer there's probably therapies in my opinion than the HBOT.
But for any brain issues for brain tumors definitely HBOT is great if you have the ability to purchase your own HBOT you can find them used that would be great as well.
Because then you have at your house you climb in there read a book turn on for an hour and it's taking an hour of your day versus having a drive to a clinic do it from home and taking two to three hours of your day so but you do want to do it very regularly by very regular and be best to do it daily.
And unfortunately all the studies with HBOT literally all the studies are doing it five days a week so it's really hard to know whether doing it less time will be as effective.
Now we've had some brain cancer patients come in twice a week and have great results with it but they were doing so many other things I don't know if it was the HBOT or was the right for the nutrition or what so I don't know it's hard to determine that.
Is there anyone who should not use a son yes me on a day like today 90 degrees.
So yeah I mean there's people that can be sensitive to heat people that have you know.
I can think about that a little bit there's people that can be sensitive to to high heat that can break out in a rash I have had patients that have done that.
But in that even to that discussion maybe break you know in a rash after a son has a good thing your body's trying to detox through your skin so that's not necessarily a bad thing.
Personally I use the soda where my head is exposed because I feel like I can't breathe in a soda that I'm in there fully in a soda maybe that's true if I say this condition.
But yeah I don't have a great answer for that question sorry okay should we call it a day great questions today.
As always I get a reminder you can email questions and just please put in the zoom call questions in the subject area of the email.
Thanks for being such a great group and as always I'll be praying for you guys and hope you be praying for our clinic and all of us here.
And again if you have specific questions that are very specific to you please talk to your liaison or schedule a time with myself or Michelle and we'd love to chat with you and make sure we get those answered we are always here for you.
I always think it's very sad when I have patients that are not doing well or something and they're never on the zoom and they never reach out to us.
You know with your plans you're we you have us at your disposal but you know we don't know what's going on with you at home so make sure that you reach out if there's any issues or if you're struggling anyway.
Alright I'll be praying for you thanks again everybody call have a great rest of the day and we will be back next week bye bye.